[Musique]
frédéric doit être beaucoup plus
disciplinés comment vous voyez la suite
de sa scolarité
je ne vois pas du tout comment ils
pourraient entrer au collège avec ses
niveaux en fait votre méthode
d'enseignement qui est à revoir
tu ne vas pas avoir le choix il faudrait
juste que tu pas sans effort j'aurais pu
le temps de jouer
[Musique]
salut fredo je suis ton double et me
voilà à ton service
je suis parti
à partir de vente us est en excellente
écoliers tu veux aller à l'école à ma
place
sans être obligé bien sûr ce serait trop
génial
encore dix minutes est souvent j'ai fini
déjà tout est correct
alors c'est lui qui va à l'école à ta
place tous les jours et il croit tout ce
que tu es devenu un intello du jour au
lendemain ou tu la trouves et salue les
loosers
ils sont vraiment dangereux ils veulent
nous voler nos vies
[Musique]
toute la province a disparu dans me
royer
il est clair qu'un 2002 étant trop c'est
chez moi ici pas chez toi c'est
l'ensemble des sept aps l'asc est
soudainement devenu qu'il faut qu'on sur
notre glace
[Musique]
mais au col ce truc est déglingué de
toute façon
[Musique]